politics can sometimes appear remote
irrelevant even to the daily lives of
ordinary citizens but not in Northern
Ireland political differences here are
deeply felt and the lack of a
functioning government is having an
impact in all parts of the public sector
transport roads Justice environment and
health all of them left treading water
but in reality they're sinking
the political stalemate has blocked
progress on important Health Care reform
waiting lists for treatment are long and
growing and excess mortality figures are
increasing people are literally dying
for a lack of political leadership what
has happened as a result of that is we
haven't had a budget and so we haven't
been able to plan so anything that has
been done at the moment is done in the
old way and no ability whatsoever to to
plan and to to think to the Future so it
is purely firefighting at the moment
with the service under so much pressure
and more pressure than we've ever seen
it under healthcare workers here in
Northern Ireland have been promised a
4.5 pay rise but unlike workers in
England Scotland and Wales who've
already received their pay rise here
without a devolved government and nobody
to sign it off they're yet to actually
receive it
it's a similar picture in Northern
Ireland's education system teachers are
currently taking industrial action over
a 30 erosion in Pay schools are
struggling to meet repairs and
maintenance costs children's education
is suffering while Northern Ireland's
political leaders dig their heels in we
are at a point now when the vast
majority of our schools at every sector
are in huge financial deficits in fact
before covert the outstanding figure for
Education was one and a half billion
pounds and for this small place that is
a lot of money the Urgent talks between
the main political parties and the
British government hold little Prospect
of a breakthrough just six months after
the last election few believe that
calling another one will make any
difference
politicians stick rigidly to their
principle but those principles have a
practical reality that means ordinary
people are left worse and worse off
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera Belfast